what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and I may be talking a little bit
quieter than I normally do but the
reason why is because I'm in a hotel
room I'm currently in Disneyworld and
I'm getting ready to go to Epcot Center
which means there's gonna be a lot of
alcohol being drink today but if you
guys are seeing this video or when you
guys see this video I will have just
crossed 1 million subscribers so I'm
excited
I do want to say thank you to everybody
who helped me to get to this point I do
want to say thank you to everybody who
helped me to pull this off it is a crazy
experience knowing that were at 1
million subscribers and I never thought
we would have gotten this far I do have
a surprise for you guys about crossing 1
million subs and if you want to find out
what the surprise is you have to go
watch the ultimate weekly recap which
will be out on Tuesday I think over our
comics torian's channel we've been
building up to this for a little while
some of the guys who are follow me on
twitter i already know what's going on I
will say 14 individuals will be chosen
to become a part of what it is that I'm
building it's the rock or I can't I
can't keep it in it's the rock or I got
rock or ready I got 15 rod Corps rings
and and I'm really excited about it
anyway this video is going to be a test
we're going to do an experiment here
last week we did a video on what would
happen if the Incredible Hulk became the
red lantern well reference that in this
video this video we're going to kill him
and we're going to test the water so
we're going to see which idea is better
to do two separate videos with a
character gaining Marvel or DC powers
whichever the case may be and then
killing them or just combining them into
one video so like next week we'll talk
about what would happen if Batman became
venom and then we'll probably just
combine how to kill him and how to
defeat him in the same video just to
kind of test the waters and see how you
guys respond we're just going to sort of
go with that and we're going to see what
happens but for those of you guys you
didn't see my Incredible Hulk becoming a
Red Lantern video I will put a link to
that in the description so you can go
back and you can watch it but for those
of you guys who a brand new here
basically we did a what if storyline on
what would happen if Hulk got a Red
Lantern ring and we enter that story
with the Hulk defeated but still alive
but I know you guys robbed core I know
you guys like the back of my hand and
the robbed core ring is on my finger
right now and I know that you're not
satisfied with just defeating these
ridiculously powerful heroes
well you want them off the board
permanently yes so that's what we're
going to do today now as we always do we
have to start with the discussion of
what Red Lantern Hulk's powers and
abilities are now this might be a little
repetitive for those of you guys who
have already watched the previous video
but just bear with me while we go over
it for those who might be watching for
the first time so of course red lantern
hold is going to have all the powers and
abilities that the Hulk would have
normally so is pretty much everyone that
has any familiarity with coloring books
knows the Hulk possesses super strength
that increases as he gets angrier with
no known upper limit he also has insane
durability to the point that it's nearly
impossible to harm him through
conventional means and in the event that
he does suffer an injury his insanely
fast regenerative healing factor can
more than make up for it
now clearly the Hulk on his own is
formidable as he's probably the
strongest earthbound character in the
entire Marvel Universe but we've already
gone over how to kill him in a previous
video so that's why we're throwing in
the Red Lantern ring somebody just make
things harder on ourselves so the Red
Lantern main draws is powers from the
rage of the person wielding it and
confers a variety of abilities on its
wielder with the most notable of these
being the ability to recharge attain a
stream of liquid rage and a form of
corrosive incendiary blood now in
addition to this the Red Lantern ring
allows it where to create hardline
constructs from red light the strength
of which is determined by the rage level
of the wear furthermore the ring allows
the user to create a protective force
field fueled by rage and also allows
them to fly so if the Red Hulk had the
Red Lantern ring like we discussed in
the previous video that we did on him
what we're faced with it's a proposition
of taking down one of the strongest
characters in the Marvel Universe who we
really can't inflict any damage on and
can heal from whatever damage he does
suffer that's also able to fly in vomit
corrosive rage blood all over the place
now in our previous video as I said we
managed to defeat the Red Lantern Hulk
but it took the entirety of the Blue
Lantern and Green Lantern Corps to do so
and that only worked after pretty much
every superhero in mobile comics had
failed to collectively take him down the
reason that worked is that the Red
Lanterns haven't
current weakness to the blue lanterns
which derive their energy from the
emotion of hope that allow the blue
lanterns to drain the power of the red
lanterns and basically that's how we
defeated the Hulk in our last video by
draining the power of the LED Lantern
rate if he was wearing but now it's time
to go a step further and not only leave
the Incredible Hulk defeated but to also
an alive also known as advertiser
friendly word The Hulk to that end we'll
start with the most straightforward way
to kill the Red Lantern Hawk this method
involves exploiting the physiological
transformation that takes place in all
those who put on the Red Lantern ring
for those that are unfamiliar what
happens when someone puts on the ring
into the ring basically replaces their
heart as well as their blood with pure
rage and the ring functions as a type of
life-support keeping its wear alive what
that means though is that if the wearer
is separated from the ring they will die
since you know they no longer have a
heart which makes leaving kind of
problematic but in theory if we can
separate the Hulk from the Red Lantern
ring he would die and we will achieve
our goal simple enough right well you
guys should know by now it's not going
to be that easy right it's not going to
be that easy
first of all saying we're going to
separate the hole from the ring is one
thing to do it it's quite another as we
said we're facing a rampaging
invulnerable rage vomiting monster it's
not like we're just gonna be able to
walk up and ask him to remove the ring
right like hey Incredible Hulk you're
really scaring old miss Jenkins man like
she's terrified of you will you please
take off the ring that's not going to
happen like he'll kill us before we even
get close enough so we're going to have
to figure out if there's a way that we
can separate the Hulk from the ring
against his will which will be difficult
but might not be impossible so members
of the Red Lantern Corps usually have an
inherent weakness to the Hulk fueled
light emitted by the Blue Lantern rings
exposure to this light will negate the
effects of rage in the red lantern which
in turn will make them weaker now if we
had enough blue lanterns then it might
be possible to completely neutralize the
rage that burns within the Hulk and then
once he's in an extremely weakened state
we move the ring
and in his life so in reality there
really is a straightforward way to kill
the Red Lantern Hulk although it will
take the concentrated power of several
blue lanterns but we can't say for sure
how many because of course there's no
precedent for this and the comics as
Hope has never gotten a Red Lantern ring
what we do know though is that hoax
capacity for Rage is very very high so
we can assume that it's going to take a
lot of blue lanterns perhaps even the
entire Blue Lantern Corps to pull this
off now I do need to point out here that
in our previous video we did get the
word Lantern ring off the Hulk after
he'd been defeated and he didn't die now
some of you are probably wondering how
that was possible but the answer is
simple since the intent was to merely
stop the whole rather than killing the
blue lanterns would have used their
healing abilities to counteract the
effects of the Red Lantern ring on the
Hulk's physiology allowing him to return
to normal obviously if the goal is to
kill the Hulk they wouldn't do that and
the hope would theoretically die when
the ring was removed but let's not stop
there I mean this is a little
anticlimactic isn't it the rod core is
not about taking the easy way out no no
all right we are not now this nerd
alright we're not taking over the
SourceFed nerd base and then killing the
channel that's not our goal we're not
going to destroy everything that we
built up we are going to take the hard
way out we're actually going to work
hard for our money so hard for our money
and it's going to work hard for us so
since we've established that taking the
Hulk down by dealing physical damage to
him it's pretty much impossible we're
still going to be focusing on taking off
the Red Lantern ring because witted he's
effectively unstoppable but how do we
get the ring off of him the first step
is clearly going to be calling the Hulk
down we have to decrease his rage if we
have any hope of getting close enough to
remove the ring
to do that we can try a couple of
methods first we can try to calm them
down telepathically
there are several extremely powerful
telepaths in Mulla Comics Charles Xavier
and the frost Jean Grey before she died
and we can try to use their abilities to
probe around the Hawks mind and turn off
the rage that's fueling him this might
work but it's not a sure thing
The Hulk has shown in the past that he
is at least somewhat resistant to
telepathy now this is kind of waxing
over the years but a combined efforts of
those three telepaths may be enough to
overcome that resistance but even then
I'm not sure how much is going to be
going on inside the Hulk's mind it's
basically just going to be overcome by
rage and devoid of any real thought
maybe this group of telepaths will be
able to dig past all the rage and
actually appeal to the Hawks conscious
mind maybe they won't it's not a sure
thing but it is a possibility but I
think a better Avenue than telepath is
another class of characters that can
alter the moods of others there are
actually a few characters in the Marvel
Universe with disability such as Luna
Maximoff the daughter of Quicksilver and
the inhuman crystal as well as Manuel
della Rossa better known as the mutant
empath because he's a pretty obscure
character that many of you may have
never heard of empath is a character
that maybe you'd in the mid-1980s in the
New Mutants series where he was a member
of the Hellions a group of mutant
students taught by Emma Frost who at the
time was the white queen of the Hellfire
Club now he's been used pretty sparsely
in comics and sent but he is really the
perfect tool for us here since we don't
want to send a child like Luna into
battle with the Red Lantern hook I mean
it'd be messed up wouldn't it like to
see like Luna just go trotting up to the
Hulk like hope will you please calm down
as I hope school like smash his little
girl I mean it'd be I don't know why
were laughing that's not funny even we
as murderous as we are we have our
limits right I mean we have the limits
of the things that we're just not
willing to do and sending a little child
in to get murdered is not okay a
teenager is perfectly acceptable though
because when I was a teenager I was a
dick and teenagers are generally dicks
so impact is perfect because he's able
to control the emotions of others
without even touching them and he can
completely negate the emotions that a
person is feeling and put them in a
pretty much catatonic state when they're
in this state empath is able to not only
control their emotions but their actions
as well so we let empath negate Hulk's
rage the Hulk goes catatonic we take the
ring off the Hulk and he dies most
likely we probably there's a really good
chance woody well I mean the Hulk has an
insane healing factor maybe he can grow
a new heart before he dies maybe he
can't at any rate we should probably
just keep calling him down until he
completely reverts back to Bruce Banner
before taking off the ring didn't we
to shoot an arrow through him and make
sure that he can't heal like the I
did during civil war queue because
Marvel was making a stupid decision
anyway Rob core if you are new here to
come as explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port proper if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
let me know how you guys feel about this
do you like the idea of doing a what-if
story and then a separate video on
killing that particular character in
that what if story or would you rather
see a what-if story and the character
killed in the same video let me know
down in the down in the comment section
and I'll try and experiment Batman or
something like that we'll we'll do a
what a story on Batman and kill him in
the same video just to kind of see how
you guys respond to that but anyway guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]